in this course you will learn machine
Learning Without libraries coding
without libraries is the best way to
learn the inner workings of a machine
learning system and it will help you
greatly improve your software
development skills Dr redu teaches this
course we already released his no black
box phase one course this is phase two
but you can still follow along even if
you didn't see phase one in this course
you will learn how to implement
classification methods such as neural
networks to recognize drawings you'll
also learn about data cleaning confusion
matrices geometry and the difference
between vector and raster data if you
want to learn how common machine
learning algorithms work under the hood
this is the course for you hi and
welcome to phase two of the null Black
Box machine learning course in
JavaScript the goal here is to take the
drawing recognizer we built in Phase One
and improve its accuracy by implementing
more advanced methods now if you didn't
complete Phase 1 you may be okay
starting directly with this especially
if you already know some basic machine
learning Concepts I will explain our
code base briefly in the beginning so
try to understand ask questions below or
on Discord and if all else fails then go
to phase one
this time we'll learn about data
cleaning it's a tedious process but I'll
teach you how to build a tool to make
the job easier then we'll learn to
visualize a confusion Matrix a special
kind of table that helps us understand
our model even better than the chart we
built last time it will be especially
helpful when working with more than two
dimensions
speaking of which so far we've only been
using two features but the K nearest
neighbor algorithm is not limited to
that all it needs is the way to
calculate the distance between data
points and I'll teach you how to do that
in 3D 4D 5D any D really I'll show you
an intuitive way to think about
multi-dimensional spaces and distances
and we'll use up to 400 dimensions in
this course
we also study another classifier the
neural network we'll use the same code
from my self-driving car course because
I want you to understand that machine
learning methods are General techniques
and algorithms we just apply to solve
different kinds of problems
now this is more complex than that
self-driving scenario and our
optimization strategy there wasn't
really good so I should teach you
something better like back propagation
but I don't know how
I tried to come up with a lesson I just
can't seem to add anything to those out
there so I'll teach you how to train the
network in Python and then take the
resulting model and just use it in
JavaScript so python will do the heavy
lifting and our Javascript app just
benefits from it
am I cheating
maybe a bit but I think that learning
this is possible is a really important
lesson here you'll see finally I'll
demonstrate deep neural networks as well
so I don't get many comments about it
now I need to stress this course is
supposed to be a learning experience I
want you to understand how machine
learning works and why we do the things
we do
we use the data you helped me collect so
we have a real challenge not some
textbook data set and we use JavaScript
because it's a high level language where
we don't need to worry about the small
things and because we can use it to
build nice user interfaces that we can
share without the need to download
install and so on I really hope you
learned to build real things not just
something that reads from files and
writes into the console another reason I
use JavaScript it's because it's not
well known for machine learning but many
people do know JavaScript and want to
learn machine learning so if this is you
you found the perfect course and if you
don't like JavaScript take it as a
challenge and implement the same things
in something you like we don't use
libraries so it's really doable I think
sound good Okay then if you plan to
follow along take the starting code from
GitHub it's similar to the last one from
phase one but a little bit different
I've added your homework submissions and
made few other optimizations as well
also remember to get the data from this
link place it next to the code like this
and you're ready to start
the first thing we'll check out is the
drawing app we use to create new data
here inside the web folder and create
our HTML
if you open this in the web browser
you'll see it looks quite different from
before but the functionality is still
the same it's going to ask you to enter
a name here and then to draw several
things but the style is different
because ninja coder did homework too and
I adopted his style
you can see these changes here in style
CSS and everything I've marked as new
style starting from beginning are things
that he has added and I commented out
previous Styles I've used in case you're
curious how to do different styling I
kept both here for reference now you'll
also notice this compatibility section
here at the top and that's because in
homework 1 I asked you to test the app
and let me know how it went there were
some problems on iPhones making the
screen scroll when you want to draw
I got a suggestion from meso to set
touch action To None Aaron commented
that these should be set to none as well
for it to work really not sure if these
are enough because I don't have an
iPhone to test but I also got feedback
from mjake and Rick and they said that I
should go here in the sketchpad
component
and add prevent default to the pointer
events which by the way Kelvin said I
use instead of the mouse events and
touch events separately
I really don't know if these comments
help because when I test on mobile it
works just fine
but please let me know if it works for
you I've added these changes on the
version of the app on my website that I
still use to collect data if you want to
submit and also in the recognizer that
will build by the end of this course
now after you're done with the drawing
and press next you're gonna get the
option to save this and it's going to
create this file that contains all the
information about the drawings you just
made
it's a Json file that if I'm going to
format like so contains the information
about the student some unique identifier
and then the different drawings the
eight different drawings Each of which
are made of a collection of paths
containing points so this is the x y
coordinate of the points and this here
is One path
that is used to draw the car and this is
another path of the car and another path
of the car so the car I drew had three
different paths and then the face and so
on
a quick note here about downloading this
Json file
Marcus suggested I set here application
Json otherwise there could be some
problems and Godlike Mouse pointed out
that I don't need to add this anchor
here in the body and it still worked
just fine now all the data I collected
from you has the same structure as this
one right here
but it's inside of this data folder and
there are a bunch of them
716 of you made drawings so that's a
total of
5728 drawings and we can visualize these
drawings using this other app that we
built but if we open this viewer HTML in
a browser we see that nothing is there
and if we open the console
there are some errors and that's because
we need to run some scripts to get
things started
these are here inside of the node folder
we open a terminal
I took Diego's advice to use the
terminal from here instead of command
prompt
change the directory to be inside of
this note folder and let's make sure
that we have node installed
and we do if not you're gonna have to
install it and then you can run npm
install inside of this folder and it's
going to automatically run all the
scripts that we need
it now generates a data set by running
this script
and what that means is that here inside
of the data we don't have just that raw
folder anymore it created a couple of
new ones
the data set folder contains two
subfolders the Json folder contains one
file per sample so now these paths here
are for one drawing the same drawing
that you can actually see here in the
image folder if you open one.png there
is a car here but because it's black and
with the transparent background doesn't
look very nice but it's okay because all
our scripts have finished now so we can
investigate this data in the viewer HTML
after we refresh it
you can see how ninja coder's style
looks here as well
I like this dark mode I think it's
better on the eyes
now what we see here on the left are
many many people the 716 who have made
drawings the drawings are here in one
row and if you click on one you can see
its features on the right highlighted on
the chart
now these features the width and the
height that we extract are the features
of the bounding box if I drag this item
up here like so to see it better
this is what the width means and this is
what the height needs
so this car has a much larger width than
the height
seems to be about double
now if we scroll down here about halfway
we're going to see a new section
starting called testing and here the
labels that you see written are what our
machine learning system thinks that they
are
the blue highlights are the correct ones
but the others are wrong and here if we
are going to click on something for
example this pencil
we will see a different kind of
highlight here on the chart let me zoom
in a little bit
and just to make things clear I'm going
to click on this pencil few more times
and notice that it's not originally
there it's a new point that we've added
now and it's categorized as a pencil
because its nearest neighbors the
majority of them are pencils here we use
50 nearest neighbors and I'm drawing a
connection to all of them so based on
the majority our machine Learning System
the K nearest neighbor classifier
categorizes this as a pencil but
sometimes like this guitar for example
seems to be a house
let's figure out why
it's quite hard to count but you can
probably see quite many houses here in
this area so it is a house our accuracy
is not that good at the moment but I'm
gonna teach you how to double it by the
end of this course
there's also this button here for
opening the sketch pad
and here you can draw something
live and in real time you're going to
get the classification if you zoom out
you're gonna see this drawing that we
made here and all of its nearest
neighbors and in this case the majority
are pencils but maybe if we're gonna
turn this into a tree
now this has changed
and the new majority
seem to be
trees we've built some really nice tools
didn't we
one more thing I should remind you of is
that we also have this decision boundary
plot is colored background right here
we can use this decision boundary plot
more effectively if we go inside of the
viewer here and pass the
testing samples
instead of the training samples to the
Chart so now when we refresh
well okay things look quite different
the decision boundary is only on this
side but that's because we have this one
sample here from armenio which I suspect
actually has a really really long width
and it was some glitch in the drawing so
for that reason it has about two width
instead of a maximum of one these are
normalized
anyway now when we look at these testing
samples here
if they lie on the same color as the
decision boundary plot indicates they
are correctly classified
but if they don't like this one right
here then it means that it's a wrong
classification so anything that looks
colorful on a different background it's
a bad classification
like this is apparently a guitar
let's review a bit how these scripts
work in the node folder the data set
generator is creating necessary
directories if they don't exist yet and
then it's generating this new form of
the data set it's going through each of
the samples one by one and it's writing
them in a new file and also generating
an image for each one
this is the function from down here
now feature extractor is going through
the samples one by one and extracting
features as specified by this feature
functions in use
you can find these feature functions in
the common folder at the top right here
and there are several functions defined
here but in use we just have the width
and the height functions that I
mentioned previously
these two are not used at the moment
they could replace the width and the
height here but these are just much
better so we keep them for now
now back to our feature extractor.js
after we get these functions we call
them here on the paths of every sample
one by one and extract the data point
we then split in training and testing
half and half and normalize the data to
be between 0 and 1. and then we just
write the output files in training and
testing respectively and there are three
formats here training training
JavaScript and training CSV and same for
testing you can find these in the data
data set
and they are right here the Json files
are here and the CSV files are here and
the JavaScript files are up here in JS
objects
testing and training JS they are the
same information written in a bit
different way because I want these to be
accessed by our scripts here but also by
our web page and also by the Python
scripts
that we have here that's what the CSV is
for and yeah I know python can read Json
too but I've seen so many people use
csvs in Python and I think it's a common
practice and you should know about it
too
so if I'm going to open here testing
Json
and I'm going to format it here you will
see first the feature names the width
and the height and then all the samples
here Car Fish House tree bicycle guitar
pencil Rock and then
another car Fish House tree and so on
all of the
2864 samples are listed here and this
long array and the point is just the
width and the height values for each of
these samples you're gonna find the same
information here in testing CSV but here
it's a different form
but width and the height and then the
label here it's something you could
easily paste in Excel as well
and the Javascript file here at the top
is the same as testing Json but with
this in front of it it's creating
essentially a global variable called
testing with this content here and I'm
not particularly happy about this code
structure it would have been much better
to use modules here and make them read
Json actually rumax suggested I do that
and I recommend you try what he says
there the problem for me is that if I
use the live server extension for some
reason everything starts lagging on my
computer I'm not sure if it's just me or
for some reason the code we're writing
doesn't work in general with the live
server extension but if you do try it
out let me know how it went now going
back to these
node scripts the last one is run
evaluation and it's going to use the k n
classifier here built using the training
samples and it's going to classify the
testing data and compute an accuracy it
also generates this decision boundary
plot and stores it here in data models
this is where that image comes from now
this image is a low resolution here
because when running this script this
part is quite slow it's going to
generate that color for each individual
pixel and the size of this image is 100
by 100 pixels but that means 10 000
different pixels there to calculate and
for each pixel you need to calculate the
distances to all of the nearest
neighbors and that's a really intensive
process so if you want to set here a
bigger value like 5000 this decision
boundary plot it's going to look much
nicer but you're going to have to wait a
few hours but you're in luck because if
you want to see how such a decision
boundary plot looks like you can open up
this resources folder and it's this one
right here
kmn 50. you can replace the one from
here if you want to see it in action on
the web page
and refresh
and now it's much sharper and you can
also zoom in to see how the edges look
like
now before we get into implementing new
things I have to mention this chart
right here I've implemented a more
optimized version of it
if we close these
things
and open the chart from the web folder
the optimization I've done is that from
the chart homework nobody did it and I
can understand why it's kind of
challenging
but I did point out what I did here and
there and you can compare with the
previous code if you're curious
basically if doing something like maybe
updating now this
Point here
the one that we are drawing I'm not
redrawing everything all the time it
just Updates this one drawing on an
overlay canvas on top of the previous
one
I did get one
optimization for the scaling
which I've added here this was suggested
by better and I also want to point out
improvements I got to my prerequisite
videos about 2D vectors and trigonometry
from Christian and Georgia Christian
rewrote the code in an object-oriented
way and used bootstrap and Georgia tells
us how to make it work if you scroll
with the magic mouse on Apple devices
also one funny thing that happened is
that these emojis now are different than
before because I got Windows 11 on my
operating system and they changed a bit
I recorded them a little bit differently
here with the filters
but they would have been just fine
otherwise as well quick mention to this
python folder here so if I'm going to
start the terminal now and go to
python folder and type
python k n we're going to get the
accuracy here as well but the code there
is really small like this is it because
we use the scikit-learn library and we
import the K nearest neighbor classifier
from there read the data from our CSV
files directly and this is actually done
here with a read feature file function
from the functions py and the python is
not really adding anything into this
project it's just showing you another
way of doing things with libraries which
is common I think
now let's begin to implement a way to do
data cleaning and speaking of cleaning I
reformatted all the code to use spaces
now and we are going to be testing on
the different window like this I got a
lot of bad comments saying I should use
spaces and now with this larger window
here I have room for that
now data cleaning means that we are
going to throw out some samples which
make our model bad for some reason
for example here this is a drawing of a
guitar but it looks like some kind of
mistake
and same for this pencil here
we can also see maybe here this one this
is not the drawing of the car it's a
drawing of a of a bird I think
so small things like that that are
probably ruining the model in some way
I'm going to want to throw away it's
very tedious to start writing down which
samples need to be removed so I'm going
to build a tool that allows me to click
on the samples here and remove them
you'll see
but now the clicking is implemented
already here
in display.js
right here where we click on the sample
container and we should inspect the
event we get when clicking here to see
if we can figure out how to maybe
control click on the item and do
something else instead of this handle
click function so I'm going to type here
EVT for event and now I'm going to open
here a curly brace and close it like
this because we're going to write more
things let's begin with the log in the
console
logging this event saving the file and
now refreshing the page and I'm going to
open the console
and click on something here and you can
see now the event is printed here if we
look at the properties we will find this
control key that is set to false and if
I hold now control when I click on
something
and scroll down here we will get another
print of the event but this one has Ctrl
key set to true so that's how we're
gonna distinguish between the two
let's remove this line
and check if
the control key is on
we are going to toggle
the flagged sample because I want to
flag something when I click on it like
that but I also want to unflag something
in case I did a mistake I don't want to
refresh the whole page if that happens
so otherwise here we are going to set
else and put this handle click in that
case now this functionality for toggle
flagged sample will be implemented in a
new file I'm going to call this data
cleaner
so let's open our viewer here and
import this new file
data
leaner
and created here inside of this
JavaScript
folder
data winner dot JS here our flagged
samples are going to go
inside the list which is empty for now
and our function for toggle flag simple
given a sample
is going to do the following
it's going to check if the flag samples
includes the ID of the sample
and if so we will remove it I first get
the index
of this sample that we clicked on
and then I'm going to remove it
by using the splice at the given index
removing one item now if we clicked on
something that isn't yet in the flagged
samples we just
add it there using the push method
like so and now we want to visually
emphasize which items are flagged and
which not we're going to make a flagged
class that is going to be added to all
the flagged samples and every time we
click on something we remove the class
from everything and then add the class
to those flagged samples kind of like a
refresh mechanism so let's first remove
this flagged class
from all items that are flagged like
this
using a for each Loop
so that each items
lagged class gets removed
and then re-added
like so we are going to Loop through the
flagged samples
get the element using get element by ID
the sample with that ID
and add this to the class list
like so
so this should work
only thing we need is a new class called
flagged and we're going to be adding
that in styles.css and I'm going to be
doing it here at the bottom of the file
it's just going to be marking everything
with a red color and I'm using here
important because I want it to be on top
of the previous style let's save this
and now refresh
and clicking things normally works as
before but control clicking gives us
this flagged View and if I click again
on the item is going to go away
so let's start flagging here the things
I pointed out previously and I'm now
going to go through all the things and
mark down anything I see suspicious
and I'm done it took much longer than I
thought it will
but it's over and um
I basically marked down things that are
incorrect or don't look at all like what
they should be
this should be a bicycle but somebody
drew a house here so sometimes these
things happen and Pi just drew mixing
things up I think they wanted to see how
the system handles those cases
but most of the data is quite good and
in total I think there is probably about
maybe 200 or so flagged samples this is
a funny one this is supposed to be a
house but many people drew a horse there
instead like gin and I think this has to
do with psychology
um basically
house and horse are very close when you
look at the letters and I asked you to
draw a house after a fish so it's after
another animal and without the context
just being told to draw this then you
might read Horse by mistake and Jin is
not the only one there are actually
quite many horses here in the database
and that's funny because it reminded me
of this uh Mandela effect if you don't
know what it is I'm gonna link it in the
description but basically there are
things that people remember differently
than what they happened and there are
things that large groups of people
remember something differently than what
what actually happened and this could be
one example of that like if we're gonna
group together everybody who has drawn
horses here and we asked them what were
they supposed to draw they will
definitely remember the horse being
asked but I never asked anybody to to
draw a horse I asked for a house
anyway let's have a look at our flagged
samples so
I'm going to type this in the console
here
and there are oh actually close to 300
of them
so 300 flagged samples that means we
have
5445 to work with and one thing I really
need to mention here is that I actually
flagged samples also in the testing set
and normally you don't do that because
testing should be as natural as possible
and we only want to do the flagging in
the training data which we use to create
our models but I did it because I don't
think it's going to impact on the
accuracy that much and I think that the
people who have made those
drawings that are messed up on purpose
will not expect the system to mess up
as well so normally that's not needed
but also because I don't want to do this
again anytime soon and if more data
comes then a lot of them are going to be
flagged already so yeah just keep in
mind that normally you don't touch the
testing samples now this array here is
quite long and I would like to
copy it somehow I'm just going to write
here Json
stringify
the flagged samples and this is going to
display all of it here
as a string like so I'm going to copy it
and go into common and utils and under
the flagged users which are people that
have drawn some bad stuff I'm going to
add here
flag samples
and I'm going to paste here
what we got
and remove the string syntax from there
and now we're going to use these flagged
samples when creating the data set to
Omit them from the raw data we'll still
keep them in the Raw data for a
reference but we won't be using them in
any of our tasks
so let's go here inside of our node
folder and data set generator
and right here a line in this for Loop
that is going through all of the samples
like so if
the sample is not flagged
so if the flagged samples doesn't
include this ID that we are generating
here
then
we do everything for it write it in the
new file and generate the image for it
here
like so and now we can run this data set
generator using node so I'm going to
start the terminal go to the
node directory and type here node
data set generator
you can put JS if you want but it will
work like this as well
and now those samples that are
problematic should be omitted from our
processing
now after the script is done we also
have to run feature extractor and this
run evaluation if we want to use the
viewer app because it's based on the
features and the decision boundary plot
is calculated using that so node
feature extractor
and node run evaluation
we are done and you can see the accuracy
is actually a little bit different 42.36
compared to what we had previously so
now when we refresh this page we will
see these changing maybe here also some
of these will look different I don't
know
and of course some of these samples will
not appear here let's see refresh
so a different result here
as expected and now the decision
boundary plot is again pixelated if you
want to have a better one then you have
to wait and put there something like
5000 or use the one that I provide for
you in the resources here
there are two of them one that you used
previously is this KNN 50 and the other
one is kmn 50 after filtering and they
look a little bit different but not by
much
so let's take this one and in the data
models I'm going to paste it here
and delete the small resolution one we
just created and rename this one so that
I remove everything except for decision
boundary
and refreshing now the page is going to
show the other one that I gave you
it's much sharper now
now if we scroll down we see that some
of these samples are missing
sometimes entire users might be missing
if I flagged all the samples and I
actually flagged all the samples of the
flagged users so those won't appear here
anymore
and everything looks fine but out of
proportion I would like to keep
everything the same size here so I'm
going to fix that by going
to Styles CSS
at our sample container
and I'm going to add here
a Max width of eight percent I notice
that this does the trick
so let's refresh
and now the things look better aligned
one more thing is that when we go here
at our halfway point where the testing
starts you will notice profit here has
his data split into some of it will be
the training data and some of that is
used for testing that's just fine it's
where the midpoint happened to be
now one more thing I want to do is say
somehow that we have this new flagging
functionality
so I'm going to add the title here an
info button and when we hover it it's
going to say some instructions how to
use that we do that in this viewer HTML
file and here in the H1 tag let me just
open it like this and type here span
with the class called info button
let's close this pan and I'm going to
add here this info button symbol
and then inside here I will have a tool
tip inside this I will just write
now let's save this and go inside our
styles
at the bottom one for the info button
let's make it red and have the cursor be
a pointer because we can click on it or
hover it and then when hovering
it's going to make the tooltip text
visible
so one more style now for this tool tip
text
and I'm gonna have this one have white
text on a red background I think the
combination goes well
and let's position it so absolute
positioning
hidden by default and a small font size
and let's have it
around a bit
and give it also padding and remove the
bold of the font because that's how they
are by default inside of this H1 tag
so refreshing
here's now our button here
and when we hover it we get the
instructions
so far we've measured the goodness of
our system using one number but if we
want to improve our recognizer we need
to understand what it does good and what
not like can it recognize pencils better
than houses for example a good tool for
understanding this is the confusion
Matrix a table that says how many items
are misclassified as something else like
here out of 343 trees 211 are correctly
recognized but three are classified as
cars one is a fish 45 is a house and so
on
now let's learn how to code this new
visualizer and don't worry you won't be
confused for long
we will draw the confusion Matrix on top
of this chart somehow and there will be
a button here to toggle it on or off so
we can still see the chart sometimes
let's go to viewer HTML
where we have our chart container and
I'm going to open it up like this and
add the container for the confusion
Matrix here
so this will be a simple div just like
this one
but it will be called
confusion
container let's give this a style and I
will go in style CSS let's look for our
chart container and put this one
underneath because they're related
and type confusion container
the position will be absolute
and I want it to be far right as
possible so right 0 and let's give this
a white background color
and I want the Z index of one the chart
has now there are some additional items
and I want it to be on top of those
let's save this and go back to viewer
HTML and add a button to toggle this
output as well so this we will refer to
as the output what is on the right and
now the toggle input function is in JS
display JS at the very bottom here I'm
going to copy it and make a similar one
for toggle
output and this one is going to use the
confusion container instead of this
input container so
Fusion container here and we don't need
anything else than doing this styling
right here let's refresh
and here's the button and when we press
it nothing really happens but if we open
the console here
and inspects
this element we can see that this
confusion container is actually there
it's just empty so it has 0 0 width and
height if we would force it to have here
maybe a width of 500 pixels
and the height of 500 pixels
then it's now going to cover the charts
perfectly and toggling it
seems to work let's implement this
component next
we will make this component very similar
to the Chart component here
it's just going to work something like
confusion is a new confusion
and here we pass the container the same
way that we passed the container for the
chart and then we also need to pass here
the testing samples and we will also
need as all the classes here so in order
they are Car Fish House three
bicycle guitar
pencil
look
and I just realized that we don't have
these
defined anywhere really so let's cut
this from here and add these to utils so
utils
classes
and now here in common utils at the top
we have these styles that contain them
somehow but it's convenient to have them
listed as well so utils
classes is equal to
what I just copied from there
and back to viewer HTML I will also pass
these options
to the confusion Matrix component as
well
okay now we Define this confusion
in another file so let's go up here
next to the other chart elements I will
also put it inside of the chart folder
so let's put here
confusion
Js inside of the chart here I will
create a new file
confusion
Js
and here we begin to type this new class
so class confusion
and in the Constructor the first thing
is the container followed by the samples
we will be passing the testing samples
here
and the classes list
and then these options
let's store these as attributes so first
samples
then passes
and I'm gonna take out the size and the
style from the options that's really
what we need here
now the Matrix inside there will be an 8
x 8 Matrix but I will actually make it 9
times 9 because I wanted to include the
header section on the top and another
kind of header section on the left those
would have cumulative values on the
columns and rows respectively
so a size for this Matrix let's say n is
going to be equal to
the length of the class is how many
classes there are plus one and now
imagine the space here divided as a grid
of 10 by 10 cells
we'll use the left Mouse and the topmost
for the labels and then the Matrix will
go in the remaining space
so the cell size that we are looking for
can be calculated here like so
we need to add another more 1 to that n
for it to be proper
we'll display this confusion Matrix as a
table so let's create a table element
using the create element the passing
table here and now I'm going to pass
here
a style we will collapse the borders
borders make
things very confusing to me at least and
we just don't need them it's going to be
quite
nice looking without you'll see
and everything will be also aligned to
Center all the text elements and because
I want to keep space for those labels on
the left and on the top I'm going to
also add here a margin left
of the cell size like so and the same
goes for margin
top now we also need to append this
table to the container
and now this table is going to be the
holder of the Matrix we need to prepare
the Matrix and fill the table
so these are going to be
two private methods
let's get the Matrix ready from the
samples and then fill the table like so
the Matrix will be an attribute here so
we'll have access to it
this free per Matrix function
is going to start off with an empty
Matrix
so let's define it as an empty list like
this
but we will have to generate its rows as
well and different rows
each of them is going to be an empty
list and
each row will be filled with n zeros for
now so I'm going to generate this Matrix
filled with zeros
like so and now we can start putting
here the values coming from the samples
so let's look through the samples I'm
going to name each sample s because it's
shorter and the next line is going to be
quite long
so the Matrix of and now I want to get
the index of the true value of that
sample so the index relative to this
classes
up here
I'm going to type
Oasis index of
the true value of the sample because
those are going to be vertically and
because the leftmost column will do
something special and have some
cumulative values I want to go past that
so I add here one
and the second
index is going to be the same but with s
dot label which is the label we
predicted using our machine Learning
System
and also the top header means shifting
here by one as well we take that value
of the Matrix at these indices and we
increase it
and that's it now we just have to return
here
this Matrix like so and it will be
passed to this attribute now the fill
table
method here
is going to add the rows and cells into
that table
so let's define it
like so
and because I don't want to type this
all the time I'm going to use this
destructuring assignment here and I will
take out
some of the attributes
from this
and now I can just use them by typing
them as such
we will look
from 0 to n like this and generate a new
row in The Matrix
this role we generate with the create
element and we use the TR element for
table row
and let's append this to the table
and now we can loop again so now we are
going to go through each individual
cells and create those
these cells are going to be
create elements
a TD element is for creating the cells
and let's style this cell
so that it has cell size pixels in width
and I'm going to copy this
or the height as well
and let's remove the padding
also and now I'm going to add the text
of this cell
to be the value of the Matrix at inj
simple as that we just have to add the
cell to the row now and we can save
refresh
and this looks as expected these zero
values will have to take care of but I
also want to take care of this top text
here and the left text here let's begin
with that
so
at the top after we create this
table I'm going to add to the container
two more things so let's generate
a div for this
top text
like so and this is going to be
saying
predicted
class
and we'll style it to have an absolute
positioning and give it a really large
font
extra large and let's set the Top Value
to 0 pixels
and I'm going to position it 50 from the
left but that's going to position its
top left corner 50 from the left so I'm
also going to transform
translated by minus 50 horizontally
and let's append this
to the container
now if I'm going to refresh
it's almost good I would like it to be
lower like this if possible so I'm gonna
give this a height equal to the cell
size and then I'm gonna use flex
positioning here to align the center
so let's go here
and give the height of cell size in
pixels
and
set the display to flex
and the Align items
Center
okay much better
but
um I would like this to be in the middle
of this right here so this should be the
middle point and that means I need to
add the margin of half the cell size
to the left so let's go here and say
so that
great now we need to do the same for the
left text
so let me just copy everything here
and I'm gonna rename this left text
and the differences are this is going to
be the label for True class
and I want this text to be rotated by
minus 90 degrees
and here
left and top should be switched so let's
move this stop here and this
left value here
now we refresh
looks good
let's calculate these cumulative values
here by adding everything
in this way and everything in that way
I'm going to go after we prepared The
Matrix here at the end of this prepare
Matrix and now we have those values the
ones that we see here
in this bottom right corner
and I'm going to use them to add to the
zero values on the left here and at the
top
so we do that with
a for Loop
so going through all the elements but
skipping the zeroth row
and another for Loop going through all
the elements of each row but skipping
the First Column so starting at one
instead of 0. and here we set the Matrix
0 and J
to be increased by matrix of I and J and
the same for the First Column also
let's refresh
and these seem to be
just right
this looks like a very small value here
and these all here seem to be small
values none of them is over 100 so
I think this calculation is correct
now these numbers here is what I would
expect to get these values should match
these values here if we would do a
perfect prediction
and if a value is bigger like for
example this 466 here is much bigger
than this 343 or
five three seven here it's much bigger
than three three nine then we are
generating too many of these items if
it's too small then we are generating
too few of these items so I would
actually like to see these at the top as
a kind of a relative difference to this
let's do that also
with the for Loop
going through all of the items at the
top
I'm going to modify them now that they
exist by subtracting the value at I and
zero basically the value on the left
there
refresh
and now you read these as here we have
too many there is an excess and here we
have too few there should be more of
this item
I think that I would like to see a plus
sign there for those particular cases
and um
and also this is zero here is useless
and should be removed so let's do that
I'm going to set here Matrix 0 0 to
nothing and
here
if the value is greater than zero
add the Plus in front of it
I'm styling these just the way I like if
you want to do it differently then
feel free but I'm quite happy with what
the end result is going to be you'll see
okay good but we don't really know what
these objects are supposed to be we can
probably remember the
Car Fish House tree bicycle guitar
pencil clock but better if we show their
the icons and they are part of the
styles
so I'm going to go here
and style these cells even more but only
if it's the top row and skipping the
first item there in that corner so if I
is 0 and J is greater than 0 Let's give
this cell a background image
and I will set this to a URL
coming from
this place so the styles
are going to contain for each class the
image and I will take the source of that
image and pass it to this URL now here
we need to do a j minus 1 because our JS
increase by one because of that First
Column header
and let's close this here like so now
I'm going to save this file
refresh and we should see on the top row
I'll add the items are but these
background images repeat now
unnecessarily
so let's go here and
say
background repeats set it to no repeat
and now let's align these the center and
I also want to give them a little bit
spacing from the top there
so let's type here
background position 50 from the left and
let's say 20 from it
okay and let's move now the text lower
so I'm gonna align it vertically to
bottom
and let's make it bold as well to be
emphasized as a header
okay good and I want to apply the same
style also here on this side
so let's just copy this
below and replace here I with J and J
with I and here J with I
as well
now this is good
but these values here the plus and minus
I would like to emphasize them using
colors as well it's hard when looking at
so many numbers otherwise so let's have
these positive values red and the
negative values
blue kind of like uh temperature scale
I'm going to go up here the color
intensity is really going to depend on
those values from the left so we could
take out this as a proportion
Matrix of i j divided by matrix of JY
like so
and let's set the value for red
if B is greater than 0 then I'm just
going to take e and multiply it by 255
that's the maximum of the red that you
can get and here zero red otherwise and
blue is going to be the same but looking
in the negative and I can't give it a
blue intensity that is a negative I have
to put here minus B times 255 or 0. and
with these I'm going to set the style
color of the cell using this RGB a
like so actually I don't think we need
this a at the end so just RGB I was
thinking to use the alpha as well but I
think that this is going to look just
fine
let's
a refresh
and you can see some kind of color here
but to get here maximum red or here my
maximum blue these differences would
need to be really really big
um they are not like this should be
double
339 so 600 something and even at our
current situation with this low accuracy
it doesn't appear so strong so I'm going
to go here and multiply this P value by
two and that's going to make it more
striking when there is a
considerable high value here
and this looks good I think
now the next step is going to be to give
these cells in the middle a background
color also depending on their value
and I'm going to use linear
interpolation here and give them some
values in between the minimum value that
we see here and the maximum value that
we see here
you can also use 0 and the maximum value
it it's up to you really but let's first
take out all of these values from our
Matrix and find out those extremes
I'm going to go here at the top of fill
table
and write
the values that we are interested in we
take them from the Matrix I'm going to
slice The Matrix
from one so that we skip the first row
entirely
and then we are going to take just the
items inside by slicing from one so that
we skip also the first element on the
left
and I'm going to flatten these so that
all of the values are in one long array
and from these I can easily calculate
now the minimum using the math minimum
function I just have to spread this
values array like so
and let's do the same here for Max
using the max function
so now we know the range where we want
to do this polar scale in between and we
can calculate the value
in between this range using the inverse
lerp function the inverse linear
interpolation function that we defined
some time ago
I do have a video on that
interpolation concept
if you want to learn more
but basically here if we are inside of
the Matrix so that we are not in header
section
so if these are positive I'm going to
get this p-value using this inverse
slurp between minimum and maximum
from The Matrix of I and J value that we
are currently displaying
and I'm going to set the background of
the cell
here using rgba so
255 for red and let's put 0 and 0 4
green and blue and the alpha is going to
be this p-value which is going to be
between 0 and 1 depending on how far it
is from mean between Min and Max so this
inverse slurp function is a really
simple function here
given an interval A and B and the value
inside the interval it first subtracts
from the value a and then divides by
this difference so you get a result
between 0 and 1 depending on this
difference
back here let's save the file
and refresh the page
and this is how it looks like it's
really easy to tell what we are seeing
here like
many houses are classified as as clocks
which is a bad thing
but um here many trees are classified as
trees this is a good thing so one thing
that I would still like to emphasize is
that anything on this diagonal
is a good thing because it means that
the item is classified as itself and
let's change the color for that as the
final update here
so
well let's say
if I is equal to J so if we are under
diagonal
I'm going to have this let's copy it
and here let's close this curly brace
else
I paste this again inside close the
curly brace and for the diagonal let's
replace here this red green blue
with 255 and set this one to zero so
this is going to be blue and again the
transparency is controlled by the same
thing
let's save this
and refresh
and we're done with the confusion Matrix
and some things here are kind of obvious
like um
the house could be classified as a clock
I can accept that because we are now
just looking at this bounding box there
and the aspect ratio so it doesn't
really matter what's inside
but some things here are really strange
like why so many pencils are classified
as clocks
this makes no sense I mean
pencils and clocks look nothing similar
even if you look at the bounding box
let's close this output and
try to figure out
what happens here
and if we go here
this is really a mess I don't see
anything useful here with so many things
displayed there what we can do is tell
the charts to display fewer items maybe
just the
pencils that are labeled as clocks
so these are very easy things to do we
just go to the viewer here
where we have our testing samples that
we pass to the chart and we can filter
them
so let's filter these testing samples
so that each sample has
is going to be kept if
it is a pencil
but it's labeled
as a clock
now I'm teaching you this not just for
the demonstration now but also that you
can inspect your data like this quite
efficiently and if I refresh here
and close this output
all we see now is the pencils and these
are pencils that are within this
gray region in our decision boundary
plot so they are labeled as clocks but
now we can click on them
ah okay
they are probably all drawn at an angle
like this
so that means that the aspect ratio is
pretty much
it's comparable to a clock
most likely all of these pencils here
are drawn at this kind of 45 degree
angle
I actually thought that pencils are very
easy to classify because they were so
clearly visible inside of this
magenta region let's actually see here
like if I remove here this filter
and refresh
toggle this output
it's like nothing else is there blocking
them
but what I understand now because of
this
confusion Matrix is that there are
actually a lot of pencils there in the
middle we just don't see them because
this visualization is so crowded
we could see them if I add my filter
back here and remove this part It's
Gonna Keep just those things that should
be pencils
and let's see where they appear now
pretty much everywhere
and since we are not drawing everything
including herminia's house
which is somewhere
there
it means that our decision boundary plot
is scaled in a nicer way these pencils
here seem to have a square aspect ratio
inside of this feature space
so far we've only been using two
features the width and height of the
bounding boxes but we saw that they're
not good enough a pencil like this can
be confused with the clock for example
today we'll introduce a new feature
which will measure how elongated the
shape is this will help to separate
pencils from other items in a third
dimension now Elia solved this problem
on Discord it was part of homework
assignments 3 and 4. so we're going to
use his code and let me briefly explain
how it works
he first computes something called the
convex Hall the smallest convex polygon
that encloses the drawing he did it
using the gram scan algorithm it's not
the only algorithm that can calculated
but Ilya used it and I think it's a good
choice
it goes like this first it only
considers the points not the paths it
finds the lowest point and from there it
calculates the angles to all other
points and sorts them then in order new
points are added to the stack again and
again but if the points are found to be
in a clockwise order the middle one is
removed from the stack repeating this
until the end gives us the convex Hall
now Elia used the edges of the convex
hole one by one to construct oriented
bounding boxes around the shape and
chooses the one with the minimum area
that's how he solved the problem
scared don't be Elia did the hard part
and we're just going to use the end
result I also think that if you study
his code it won't take long before you
understand it
we're gonna implement the new feature
using ilia's help
who solved homework assignments 3 and 4
pretty much
I'm gonna give you this link in the
description
let's copy this code
and I'm also gonna write it in a file
called geometry.js
let's go and put it inside of common
here create a new file
geometry
Js
and I'm going to paste his code here
format it slightly and at the top
let's write where this code belongs to
originally
and I'm gonna paste this link
right here as well
and here we find all the functions
needed by the algorithm
this Returns the lowest point and it
keeps in mind that the y-axis goes
downward
then here the points are sorted relative
to their angle
and here is the actual implementation of
the Graham scan algorithm
the points are added to this stack right
here and then the stack is returned
there's also this helper function here
that calculates the width and height of
a box aligned to the hole in some way
these are all Vector operations and they
should be clear if you've watched my
prerequisite video
but basically it finds out what is the
left top right and bottom and then
calculates the width and height using
that
Elia also returns these vertices here
which were returned back in the original
space they're not really needed I think
but it helps debugging and you'll see
will make use of them
now this one is basically going to
iterate through all the possible
orientations and find the box that has
the minimum area
and then everything is returned here
like so
two other helper functions here one for
getting the angle and one for
calculating the distance the squared
distance actually because Ilia only
needs here the relative distances and
there's no point in taking the square
root anymore it's a kind of an
optimization now that's the code pretty
much and it looks good but how can we be
sure it's good
the only way really is to test it we
could write unit tests for it but I
prefer to debug visually
so let's go to our data set generator
file here
and now where we generate the image file
here I'm going to
run elia's code
take out the vertices
from the minimum pounding box
and here we need to pass an object
containing points
so I'm going to flatten the paths and
just take the points from there and make
sure that you pass here this it's
required and then with these vertices
I'm going to draw
them with the red color on the canvas
now let's save this and open a terminal
go to the node directory
and here let's run the data set
generator
like so and while it's doing it we can
check the
progress here
and we can see now this rotated pounding
box
but it's missing one of the lines there
let me just stop this
and fix it by passing the first vertex
one more time at the end so what I will
do is I will create here a new array
containing all the elements of vertices
and then one more time
vertices of zero the first vertex vertex
is just a funny word for a point
now if we run this again
and check what happens in the images
it's closed as we expect but I would
like to see also the whole
and just to make sure that whatever
happens here is correct so let me close
this one more time and in the geometry
I'm going to go
here where the hole is also calculated
and I'm going to add it
here
let's save this file and back in data
set generator
I'm going to also destructure here the
wall that we are passing now and I'm
going to copy this one more time with
hole here and maybe let's put this color
to Blue
let's try one more time
now we can really debug what happens
here and make sure that the bounding
boxes and the convex holes are what we
expect
really
while this is processing let's go and
Implement our new feature
using Elias code so in feature functions
I'm going to import here
at the top
geometry if it's undefined I'm doing
this check because we're going to need
to
also use this file on the web
and geometry might be there already
and now the feature name is going to be
elongation
and what we do to calculate this
is take out the points by flattening the
paths
and then we just get the width and
height from Helios function here
as before
and we return here
the maximum between the width and height
divided by
the minimum
of the width and height
and now in practice it could be possible
that the width or height is zero from
the drawings like if somebody draws a
perfectly horizontal line then the
vertical coordinate is the same for all
the points and then height is going to
be zero and then this is going to be
zero so typically what you can do in
this case is wrap these
like so
and add the plus one to each of them
because it kind of makes sense
if you think about
pixels that it does have some kind of
height even if it's zero from this
Vector point of view and it's just one
way that we avoid this problem I'm not
really sure if it happens here but I was
thinking about this division by zero so
anyway
this new function now we can add right
here
elongation
and get the elongation
and for it to work we need to adapt our
distance function in utils
right here to use the third dimension as
well
so we could do that for example like
this
by just including here the difference on
this third dimension denoted by this 2
here so 0 1 2 means one two three but
it's
nicer to write this in a more General
way so we don't have to do this again
and again every time we add a new
dimension so let's remove this and
initialize the variable called squared
distance
with zero and loop through all of the
dimensions of the first point one by one
and add to this squared distance
the difference on that Dimension squared
and here we just return the square root
of that squared distance and now we
don't have to bother with this function
anymore so let's try to extract these
new features now I'm going to go here
and type node feature extractor Js
and now let's run our evaluation
and look at that we went above the 50
mark
quite a significant Improvement here
let's see the results on the web as well
so I'm going to go here and make a few
changes in viewer HTML we need to import
also geometry now and I'm going to do it
here under utils I think it's a good
place
and let's save the file
and refresh the page
and something is not right because this
input shouldn't be there
and if I open the cons so
I see there are some errors in Geometry
there and I'm quite sure they are
because this input is empty and it's
giving a list of
zero points basically
and let's have a quick look here
insides of geometry.js
there are sometimes used points from the
first index second third index at least
so we would need to have at least three
points for this code to work properly
and we can do that in multiple ways
maybe we could go here and viewer HTML
at the bottom and only update what's on
the sketch pad only process that
for example his
there are paths and if they have more
than three points
so here I'm writing the opposite and I'm
saying return if it's not like that so
this would work here
there's no more error but the problem is
if we do draw something here
and then maybe
revert everything it doesn't process
anymore this empty page so I would
actually like to return 0 with and zero
height if not enough points so I don't
keep this update here instead I cut it
and I go in Geometry Js
in the function that calculates here
the minimum bounding box and I say
paste but only focusing on the points
and
if they are too few I will return now
a width of zero height of zero and let's
return the vertices on the whole and I'm
just going to return all the points
so points points
like so
now this should work again without an
error here
right
and if I draw something on the input
and I undo it also changes so nothing is
a car in this model's mind now this is
much better accuracy and also if we look
at the column here and the row here the
pencils are doing really really good now
so we got what we wanted
and let's toggle this output to see the
chart as well
and this is quite confusing now because
we are having three dimensions so we
should plot that elongation also on the
third dimension
but it's Overkill I think and soon we're
gonna have even more Dimensions than
that and what do we do then also this
decision boundary plot it's not proper
at the moment uh it should be a decision
boundary
Cube not a rectangle like this one but
we could start slicing this Cube somehow
if we really want let me first actually
remove these
samples from here because they are
confusing for what I want to show you
next
and I do that here in the chart options
by typing
hide samples set to true and then for
that decision boundary plot
in run evaluation here I'm going to go
at the bottom and here it's doing the
prediction with just two Dimensions so
we basically get the same as only with
the width and height here
because the distance function is
implemented based on how many dimensions
this point has
so to have a three-dimensional plot we
need to add another
value here and it would actually require
another for Loop and passing here
another dimension but this will just be
a set of images on top of each other so
we have to slice this Cube somehow and
now I'm slicing it at the minimum
elongation and I could slice it in other
parts as well if I want but let's just
see what we get here
and I'm going to run this evaluation
again
and refresh
toggle the output
and you can see the pencils are actually
gone but that can't be true because
pencils are being classified correctly
and they are even classified the best
according to our confusion Matrix here
what happens is that the slice that we
are doing in this cube with the minimum
elongation doesn't contain them we would
have to slice further away maybe with
the maximum elongation since they are
the most elongated shapes there
so let's try that put here one instead
regenerate the decision boundary plot
refresh the page toggle the output
and everything seems to be pencils so if
it's the maximum elongation our model
thinks that everything should be a
pencil here but there must be a place
where it kind of contains pencils and
something else so let's try cutting this
Cube maybe in the middle
regenerate the decision boundary plot
refresh the page
toggle the output
and seems like even here everything is a
pencil
okay let's go even smaller maybe 0.2
refresh the page
toggle the output
and now we see something like that
basically the pencils are creeping out
somehow and being replaced with
something else as we Traverse this this
cube in the z-axis
but let's inspect the samples a bit too
I'm going to go to viewer HTML and
remove this height samples
let's comment it for now
and here
let's still focus on the pencils but
only those pencils that are
incorrectly
predicted
let's refresh
toggle the output
and here are the incorrectly predicted
pencils but this decision boundary plot
now is kind of useless because we don't
really understand it anymore with the
third dimension there like these are all
wrongly classified pencils but some of
them appear to be over this magenta
patch here because they might be in
somewhere close to low elongation so if
I would click something here you can see
this pencil is very fat so to speak so
it's in that
Zone where there was no magenta at all
maybe and that's why it's categorized as
a house and not a pencil
this seems to be a guitar it's also a
little bit thicker and all of these
bounding boxes and
convex Halls look great I think
really good job Ilia
what happens here this looks interesting
this looks like a problem but what I
think is here is that there is actually
a small point there that somebody drew
and in our system if somebody makes a
point it's not going to be drawn because
there is no thickness basically
but it might be there let's inspect a
little bit so it's this five zero seven
eight image
I'm going to go in our data data set
Json this time
and five zero seven eight
is here
let me format this
and I actually see here the first path
even
it's exactly the same point repeated
twice so I guess this can happen too
basically there's one path there that is
small and it's not rendered by our
software but the calculations pick it up
so it's not really a problem with ilia's
implementation maybe it's a problem with
mine with my visualization but I don't
want to bother with with things like
this so let's forget it's an issue
let's focus on clocks next most clocks
are round so the next feature we'll
Implement is a kind of roundness
measurement I've already done something
like this in my AR portal drawing game
tutorial here on YouTube so you may know
it already but this time we combine it
with the convex hole from before
to measure the roundness we first
calculate the length and the area of
this shape and compare it to the area of
a circle with the same length if you
want to learn why the circle has the
largest area I have a video on that
it's quite intuitive though so I don't
think you really have to watch it now
get ready for another round
to calculate the roundness I'm going to
add some functions here inside of the
geometry file
let's begin with the function called
length of a given polygon now this
polygon is just going to be our paths
but I write it here as such because I
think it gives the idea that the
function will consider the first point
also at the end to Loop
and let's implement it
unlike so initialize the length with
zero
and then Loop through the points
like so
and get a value for the next index so
next index
is going to be I plus 1 but when we are
going to have I is equal to polygon
length minus 1 at the end adding 1 to
that will give us an index that is not
good and we should Loop that around to
be zero again so I'm going to use the
module operator
like this
and add to the length the distance
between the polygon of I and the polygon
of next I like so
let's return now this length and because
we're using utils here I need to add it
here at the top to include it
if it's not existing and then
include it like that
and we are adapting now this file from
Ilia here so let me just write a quick
comment here adapt it from the original
author now the next thing we'll need
here is to calculate the area of a
polygon and we'll do that by breaking it
into triangles
according to
some fixed point and calculating the
area of each triangle and adding them
together
so let's say our fixed point is going to
be
a and that will be polygon of zero and
now we Lu
from I is equal to 1
and less than polygon length minus 1
this time because we're also going to
use this next index here but we don't
want to Loop anymore
and here let's define B as the polygon
of I and C as the polygon
of I Plus 1. so a is going to be fixed
but b c is going to change from those
next to I and then B is going to be the
previous C and we get the new C and so
on until we add up all the triangle
areas
and for the triangle area I'm going to
write the separate function
here called triangle area between these
three points
and let's return the area here
to get the area of a triangle we're
going to first calculate its side length
and then use Heron's formula it's one of
my favorite formulas I learned in school
now I won't prove it here but you can
take it as a homework and prove it
yourself maybe using the Pythagorean
theorem
anyway this way of measuring the area of
a polygon is not the only way in fact in
the portal drawing game I mentioned
earlier I use the shoelace formula and
that one works with concave polygons as
well
check it out if interested
so the formula works by calculating the
lengths of the triangles so typically we
refer to as the side length of a of B
and C
and we do the same thing here for
B and that will be
A and C and we get here C and that will
be
A and B so these are the side lengths
that we just calculate as the distance
between those
and then we Define p as the semi
parameter
or half parameter the half length of the
triangle so this is going to be a plus b
plus C divided by two and this is
Heron's formula so the area will be the
square root of the half parameter times
P minus a times P minus B times P minus
C we just need to return it here
and now we can use these two functions
the area of the polygon and the length
of the polygon to implement our
roundness function
the roundness function
is going to take the polygon as a
parameter and first thing we do is get
its length
hand area
using the but functions we built
previously
and now let's calculate the
radius of the maximum Circle that could
be built using this length
so that would be the length divided by
2 pi like this
and the area of such a circle would be
pi times the radius squared so the
roundness is going to be
the area divided by this
circle area
and here we could return the roundness
but in case this circle area ends up
being 0 then this roundness is going to
be not a number so
to be safe we are going to check here
if it's not a number let's just return 0
in that case otherwise we return this
roundness value and that's it now let's
debug if what we implemented works and
I'm going to go here in data set
generator where we were previously
drawing these vertices and the whole to
debug Elias code and let's include now
our roundness calculation here
so we can do that like this
roundness is equal to
calling geometry dot roundness on the
whole this time because that's what we
want to measure the roundness of
and now I won't need these vertices
anymore I will just focus on the hole
here but I will give it a different
color the color will range between blue
and red if it's blue it means a low
roughness and if it's red it means a
high roundness
so let me go here and say
R for red is going to be the floor of
this roundness
multiplied by
255 because that's the range of the
colors
then green is going to be zero we won't
care about that and for blue I'm just
going to copy this and invert it here so
1 minus this roundness multiplied by
that
and this is B here with this we create a
new color
and I'm using here these template
literals
and replacing the color here when
drawing the hole
now let's save this and open the
terminal
in the regenerate the data
and let's check it out as it's doing it
here in the data data sets image
this looks
reddish
okay
okay much red here in this house
pencil is quite blue here
and the clock is red as expected let's
go here and make this line thicker
I'm going to add here
10 pixels in width and I will modify
this draw path function
from here
to accept also
the width let's set it by default to
three and replace the three that was
hard coded here previously and let's
write the function for extracting this
roundness feature as well I'm going to
go in feature functions and type it here
it will be get aroundness of the paths
and let me copy here this code from the
elongation because we're going to call
ilia's minimum bounding box function and
instead of width and height we are going
to extract the whole now and then return
here
the roundness of that hole like so let's
add this also to our feature list here
and roundness
get around this
and regenerate the data
extract the features
and run our evaluation
and look at that we're getting above 60
now
but this decision boundary won't be
proper there because it's not yet
slicing the hyper Cube four-dimensional
Cube now just yet
we'll get to that but first let's just
refresh the page
and our colors here are not proper
because they are inverted by Ninja
coders new style here let me just go
back here
in data set generator and invert these
as well so 255 minus that 255 minus that
255. minus that
and re-run everything
and the features
and run the evaluation
forgot that hypercube again but we'll
get to that
Okay so
refresh and now it's how I want it red
for these and you can see
a lot of clocks are red
but there is a lot of red everywhere
because things tend to have a high
roundness value
if you look at the convex hole here in
general if you would like to
differentiate better between really
round things like these circles here
that are making the clocks
you could
use a non-linear function here for the
roundness like maybe Square this value
or even a higher power will make the
difference even more significant maybe
like
fifth power here
you'll notice that generating these
decision boundary plots is becoming
slower and slower because the
classification is becoming slower and
slower because we're adding more and
more Dimensions so that distance
function has to do more work for all of
the neighbors repeated many many times
let's refresh
and now these differences are more
striking the circles here do appear more
reddish than anything else
but our decision boundary plot still
looks the same as before here and that's
because in our run evaluation here we
are still sending three dimensions to it
when we now have four and we could in
principle add one more Point here but to
make this function General enough so
that we don't have to do this every time
we can just remove this and use a while
loop until the length of this point is
going to be the number of Dimensions
let's just add the value here so maybe
point
push and I'm just going to slice at the
lowest value in the elongation and
roundness dimensions and get something
but this is not really going to be
something useful when we have so many
dimensions so this decision boundary
plot is only useful for two Dimensions
really
let's see what we get we just have to
run the evaluation now so that we get a
different decision boundary plot
and refresh the page
toggle the outputs
and that's
how it looks like apparently not
interesting really let's go back to the
confusion Matrix here and notice how
white this section is becoming here and
how good our system became at
recognizing
pencils and clocks which is what we were
trying to do looking at elongated shapes
and looking at Round shapes started
working now what doesn't work is the car
being confused with Fish And The Fish
being confused with the car we have this
small square here and actually cars are
also confused with bicycles and fish the
same because these tend to have the same
aspect ratio and their
convex holes tend to look similar as
well the guitar as well actually gets
confused with the car and the fish for
similar reasons I think we just didn't
try to extract features that would help
distinguish these and we could like cars
are much more blocky I think and fish
are much more organic in shape maybe
looking at this kind of a
curviness how curvy the lines are it may
help to recognize the fish and
distinguish them from Cars also from
bicycles
the bicycles well they do have circles
here so maybe using the roundness
measure in some other way could help to
recognize those
maybe looking for corners
when I look at houses they typically
have some triangles there
Corners many corners there is a problem
when considering triangles and let me
show you let's close this
and start our input here
if I'm going to draw a house I could
draw it for example like this and now
start making a rectangle here and a
triangle here
like so and these could be recognized
relatively easy if you look at the data
that we collected because there are
three independent shapes so you could
maybe recognize that one is a triangle
one is a rectangle and there is a flat
line here but what if you draw the house
like this
now the second shape will be just this
kind of
upside down U shape and then
the roof I'm not going to draw a full
triangle I'm just going to draw this
upside down V shape to me both of them
look pretty much the same but the data
that we store is significantly different
this has just two sides this has three
this has three sides this has four and
you can draw these in different ways but
the problem is if we would like to
extract things like triangles or
rectangles or these kind of shapes
looking at the vector data is not as
easy as looking at the pixel date so
we're gonna study how to access pixels
next
so far we've been working with the data
in raw Vector form the coordinates of
the points and the paths they create but
that's not what we humans see when we
look at the drawings we see the pixels
and some features can be calculated more
meaningful if using those like these
drawings look the same but their Vector
representation is very different and it
would be quite strange if they would not
be classified as the same thing wouldn't
it
if you've never worked with images you
can watch this video where green Rado
explains how to make an image recognizer
that works with the camera
I think it's a good watch especially now
that you have a good understanding of
machine learning already
now I won't teach you any sophisticated
image processing techniques but I want
to set you up just in case you want to
experiment more
there are a bunch of things that can be
tried out with this new approach
self-study them ask me questions in the
comments or on Discord and we'll try to
figure things out
let me show you how we can access the
pixels from the canvas
I'm going to do this in the console here
and type
sketchpad CTX getting the context of
this sketch pad that we're drawing on
and get image data
from 0 0 which is the top left corner
using the sketchpad canvas width and the
sketch pad canvas height so I want to
get all of this information
and we press enter we get this which is
containing some information about color
space the width and height 400 by 400
and this really really long data array
here now this data array is going to be
filled with the zeros pretty much
because that's what is drawn on the
canvas now
everything is actually
transparent black this stands for red
green blue Alpha of the first pixel in
the top left corner on the canvas
and this is the pixel on the right of
that so red green blue Alpha red green
blue Alpha and so on if I'm gonna draw a
line here on the canvas and run the same
code here again
you can see zeros here but at some point
we start getting some values and these
are the values from this line that I
drew here and they only appear as Alpha
values because the lines are black
actually they are here inverted because
of the styling but basically anything
with an alpha is a pixel that is
lighting up
so that's what we want to extract from
here really we don't care about colors
we just want to know which pixels are
visible and which not
so if I'm gonna bring this code back
here again we can filter this to take
just the fourth item in the array every
fourth item in the array using
filter on the data and taking the value
and the index
so here we're gonna filter using this
index if modulo 4 is equal to 3.
and this gives us that just the alpha
values and they are 160
000 so this is 400 times 400 a matrix
written in linear form pretty much
so let me close this console and write
the code to extract these pixels
in our feature functions I'm going to go
in common feature functions and here
below the roundness feature I'm going to
implement a function to get these pixels
it won't be a single number as an output
it will be all the pixels it's not a
feature yet but eventually we'll use it
as a feature as well you'll see and I'm
gonna write it here in the feature
functions for now
so
let's right here get pixels
and given the paths Now by default we
used this 400 by 400 pixel canvas all
the time I'm gonna set the size here
equal to 400 but we can set the
parameter here to get the pixels from a
smaller canvas if necessary let's first
Define our canvas and I'm using let here
and setting it to null because now I'm
going to do a trick I'm going to try
to initialize the canvas
for the web
by
asking the document to create the canvas
element like this
and then setting its width
the size and its height to the size like
so
but if this fails it probably means that
we are doing this in a node and I'm
going to catch an error I'm not going to
worry too much about what the error is
because in our environment this can only
be the reason why it doesn't work that
we're trying it on node so this code
here is for node
and here we have to require the create
canvas function
from node node modules
canvas where the canvas was installed
and then our canvas can be
initialized with create canvas size and
size like this
now the code should work both on web and
inside of node
and we can now get a reference to the
canvas context
like so
and draw these given paths here
on this new canvas
we then get the image data
from the whole canvas
and take out just the alpha values that
we're interested in so I'm just going to
return directly image data dot data dot
filter value index and then
index module for when it's equal to
three so every fourth element will be
returned now we're drawing here and we
haven't included that file here yet so
I'm just going to do that real quick
troll draw
like so
and now let's test our code in the data
set generator again I'm going to go here
in node data set generator and we need
to include the feature functions here
so feature functions
and feature functions and let's go down
where we are generating the image and we
don't need this fancy stuff anymore
because this new visualization will be
just me writing some text on the images
how many pixels are visible
so let's first access these pixels
using our newly created function and
let's store the number of pixels in a
variable which we're gonna call
complexity because I'm eventually going
to make a feature from this and
complexity just means the more pixels
the more complex it is
so let's say complexity is and we count
now
how many
values are non-zero these are just the
alpha values remember that
so if they are visible they will be
counted
and then let's just draw some text
this complexity value and let's use blue
color
now this draw text doesn't exist so
let's save this file and go here to draw
JS we can draw paths but we can't draw
text just yet so we need to implement a
function for this given the context and
the text and the color we set it to Blue
but let's give this one a default color
as well
and now the location by default will be
0 0 where we want the text to be in the
top left corner and let's set a
relatively large size because we are
just printing there those small
thumbnails in the viewer the text should
be quite big
now this function is going to
first set the font and I want it bold
let's concatenate here the size and I
will use Courier font
because I want the text to be in the
screen I want the bass line to be on the
top because if zero zero chord then it
is used otherwise the text would just be
over that then we wouldn't see it
and I'm gonna put here text Baseline
stop
and let's set the fill style to the
color
and
fill the text
at this location I'm just spreading the
array into the two X and Y components
and that's it let's save this and open
the terminal
make sure we are in the node folder
and let's
generate our data set once again and
while it's doing that we can quickly
check what happens here in data data set
image
and this is a number that probably works
meaning it's the number of visible
pixels here
maybe it's okay we'll see later when we
can visualize them in the app but while
it's doing this I'm actually going to
implement the complexity function that I
mentioned so let's go to our feature
functions here below the new function we
just created
and the complexity function is going to
be just get complexity from the paths
and it's going to return this one number
so first thing that happens is we
extract these pixels
and now we're going to count how many of
them
are visible
like so and we can add this new
feature here
and get complexity like so now we're
dealing with this five dimensional
feature vector and I don't really know
how good this feature is going to be I
don't really have High Hopes I just want
to teach you how to work with pixels and
then it's up to you
you can look online find some help how
to do image processing if you're curious
but I won't get into that
now this is done let's also
extract the features
and this is probably going to take some
time now because doing this pixel
manipulation is time consuming each
image is 400 times 400 so a lot of
calculations let's add here also this
kind of progress indicator
so I'm going to go to
feature extractor
and
this for Loop here where we are looping
through the samples let's rewrite it
using a classical for Loop
looping through all the samples like
that and let's here initialize the
sample list samples of I
and at the bottom here let's print the
progress using our utility function
high and samples length
minus one for a hundred percent
now next time we run this code we will
know how long it takes at the moment I
have no idea so
I just have to be patient
band it's done let's now run the
evaluation
there is some improvement it jumped to
66.13 here
and now this decision boundary plot is
going to use all of the features because
we implemented in a general way last
time but I don't really care about this
decision boundary plot anymore it's not
very usable as it is when more than two
dimensions
so we're done let's refresh the page
and this is what we get we see now the
numbers here
and I think they're proper
this is a very small value here 1000
something when most of them of several
thousand and you can see just a few
pixels showing up for this small pencil
I think that this is correct but
thinking about it it's kind of unfair to
say that this is less complex than this
because they kinda look the same if we
talk about the feature meaning
complexity maybe we should scale these
items so they fill the whole canvas and
then count how many pixels are lighting
up
let's try to do that I'm gonna teach you
a little bit of image processing anyway
so let's just scale these and stretch
them to fill the whole canvas and see if
this feature improves or not but I won't
insist more than that
in feature functions
where we extract our pixels here I'm
going to pass another parameter to the
function saying if we want to expand or
not so that the drawn image fills the
entire canvas
and if it's set to True which will be
the case by default then we go here
before drawing the paths and rescale
these paths somehow
we check if we need to expand
and if we do I'm going to take the
bounds first the minimum maximum on the
X and Y so let's take out the points by
flattening the paths
and these bounds
will be an object
with left equal to the minimum
points
only looking at this x chord and it's
the first chord in it here
so I'm going to copy this like so for
the right
with the maximum here
and let's copy both of these for the top
and the Bottom now these will be
one here
because we're using the second dimension
we are now going to remap these points
and generate some new paths with
remapped points so let's write here
New Paths and this is going to be an
empty array
and we're going to Loop through the
paths
pass by path
and now we're gonna generate new points
from the path's current points so these
will be
in this variable and we'll use the map
function where we remap each point p
to be a new two-dimensional array
the first will be
remapping using inverse slurp
between left and right
using p of 0 and this is going to give
us a value between 0 and 1 depending how
far from left to right we are so we have
to scale this also by the size of our
canvas
now I'm going to copy this again here
and this will be between
top and bottom
using the First Dimension here now we
need to push these new points into our
new paths every time we create them
and finally we can draw here the New
Paths on the canvas
so New Paths like so
and this will go in the else Clause so
here we have else
we do that because in this case we don't
want to expand anything
now if we open our terminal
and regenerate
our data
if we look here we will start to see
that
the values are different than before but
I would also like to visualize what we
did exactly so while it's running I'm
going to redo the visualization part in
this data set generator here and I'm
going to show the new image that we get
after expanding them
so here after we have our pixels I'm
going to figure out the size they are
going to be a square canvas always so I
just take the square root of these
pixels
length
and then let's get the image data that
we have on the canvas at the moment I
just need the data structure essentially
and
I'm going to Loop
through these pixels one by one and I'm
going to write on top of this image data
the values that we currently have
so to do that I'm going to consider just
this Alpha value others will be 0 for
red green and blue so starting at the I
times for index because they come in
group of four I'm going to set the image
data data at the start index to zero so
this is for red now and this has to be
copied
three more times here and now we're
going to set
the green
and the blue
and the alpha component
this is not zero this will be the alpha
that we calculated previously
and now we put this new image data on
the
context so put image data image data 0
0.
and I don't think I need this complexity
value appearing anywhere here when
debugging I know the number of pixels is
calculated correctly already
let's regenerate the data
okay this is done and now let's extract
the features
we can see how this progress indicator
works now
much slower when we're dealing with
these pixel values
okay and now let's run the evaluation
and done a little bit improvement from
previously but not much and this is what
we get the images are now stretching
all over the canvas there
and
I kind of like this view because now we
can see the drawings much better even
for those who made small images they are
stretched here like that but remember
that all we do with these stretched
images here are counting the pixels as a
kind of complexity measure all the other
calculations still happen the same on
the raw Point data one thing I am really
curious to see is
arminio's house
aha
it was like that
for some reason the app registered some
point very very far away and that's why
its width is so huge
now let's try drawing here
and I do sense a little bit
slower reaction time here because every
time we make a new update to the drawing
it's going to take the features
including this pixel feature which is
slower to calculate and
um
basically it takes a little bit longer
time here I would say it's still real
time
we move on to neural networks next and I
don't have the patience to teach you
what they are but don't worry I know
just a person to do it take it away red
Rado
neural networks are Computing systems
inspired by the biological neural
networks in our brain
these are some neurons
these branch-like structures receive the
signals
when stimulated enough a neuron will
fire a signal through its Axon
so a single neuron does something really
simple and intelligence only comes when
they work as a team
you see your brain has 86 billion
neurons
you also have quite many of them in your
spinal cord and sensory organs like in
your eyes and ears
these sensors send signal to some
neurons that pass it to the brain
there the processing happens like a
chain reaction where some neurons fire
some don't eventually signals arriving
to motor neurons that pass them through
your spinal cord and make some muscles
contract in very specific ways
hey
A lot happened in just a split second
let me try to slow this down and explain
it to you
pay attention
sensors inside the ear pick up
compression waves from the air and send
signals to the brain which figures out
the direction based on different
intensities
signals then travel to neck muscles tell
them to contract and turn the head in
that direction
the eye catches a glimpse of what's
happening and new signals travel to the
brain
peripheral vision is blurry but good
enough information exists to detect some
kind of object approaching and new
signals travel to facial muscles to
contract and protect the eyes from
getting hurt eyes are really important
at the same time the brain begins a kind
of Defense protocol by sending signals
throughout the body
time passes and the image becomes more
clear
the brain does pattern matching and
recognizes the object as a ball
contextual and historical information
will play an important role in what
happens next let's stick to the first
one
the brain concludes there is no threat
and uses knowledge about physics it
learned during its lifetime to predict
where the object is headed it then sends
new signals to the muscles to contract
in slightly different ways to catch the
object instead of blocking it and the
rest is history
one history where the brain did the good
thing and not much happens afterwards
but sometimes this happens and the Brain
learns it did something wrong and
configures itself so the same thing
doesn't happen again
hopefully
anyway I'm feeling really good about
myself now that I know my brain can do
something like that in an instant
hope you do too
our cars in your own network will do
something like that
neurons on the first layer will be
connected to the sensors
they will send signals forward a few
times and the last layer will be
connected to the car controls to make it
actually do something
spoiler alert will be working with
relatively small networks here but
that's okay because we actually don't
need very large networks to solve this
problem
now that you have a basic idea take the
code from the link in the description
you'll need it to follow along but
beware I will just briefly go through it
and if you really want to understand it
go watch these two videos first
of course watching the whole
self-priving car series is even better
there is one thing about what redrado
said in the beginning that bugs me
so a single neuron does something really
simple
I got this comment from Mikhail and I
should point out that biology is really
not that simple we don't fully
understand how brains work to this day
but a simple model like that is all we
need to build an artificial neural
network I definitely don't want you to
draw the wrong conclusion and that
comment made me think twice about my
wording
I've added the two files here in common
we have Network JS now
and in web JS we also have viewer JS
here
viewer.js is pretty much the same as in
that tutorial except that I made these
output labels
be images now there I used emojis but
here I wanted to use the colored emojis
we generated earlier
and there are a few other small tweaks
here and there but pretty much the same
code as you've seen there and network JS
here is the same code from the tutorial
with this small difference here instead
of how it was originally written
because in the self-driving car case the
car could press two keys at the same
time like maybe accelerate and go to the
left
but here we need to decide which is
going to be the winning class so we are
leaving these outputs as the raw value
there and we will select the class to be
the maximum value that we get
I've also added here this export so that
it fits with our current structure
but other than that it's exactly the
same we have here the neural network
made out of different levels
the level having inputs outputs biases
and the weights we have methods for
randomizing these weights and biases
because that's how we knew to optimize
in that other course we just tried
randomly different networks and hoped
for the best we kept the best one all
the time then the feed forward algorithm
just implements that summation and
outputs all the outputs
to feed forward for the whole network
just feed forwards each individual level
like that and the only difference is
really this line of code here but if
you've watched that tutorial you know
what it means now to use this new code
we will build a new classifier next to
our KNM classifier that we had here
already and I'm going to copy this one
for reference let's copy and paste it
here with a new name
I will rename this file
mlp.js
MLP stands for multi-layer perceptron
and I think it's a good name here
because neural network is kind of like
an N from here so I want to keep this
different and it will also match with
what we do in Python later on
now we will modify this code inside of
mlp.js so here we have
MLP now and let's export here also
MLP like so
and I'm going to empty here the
Constructor we won't save the samples
here this model doesn't store the
samples it's what makes it much more
efficient than this K nearest neighbor
let's remove them from here as well and
I'm going to empty also this predict
method but I will keep the return so
that we know what structure we need to
return things in now the Constructor is
going to take as parameters the neuron
counts
we need to know how many neurons we
should use and also the classes the
model needs to know what are the options
let's save these here
as attributes of this MLP
so the classes
and now let's initialize a neural
network with the code from the file we
just added and pass here the neuron
counts
so this we need to include here same as
we include utils but here we include the
neural network
like so
from the network
JS file
and the prediction here is what changes
we just get the output
from the neural networks feed forward
algorithm when we pass this point the
parameter from here
and this network that is stored as the
attribute of the class right here
from these outputs we calculate the
maximum so let me use math Max and
spread here this output array and let's
get the index of the element
with the maximum
like so
and the label of that is going to be
taken from classes at that index
simple as that
now for consistency with the KNN I will
keep here an object with the attribute
label but we don't have any nearest
samples here it's gonna be null
let's save this file and to evaluate
this MLP model I'm going to copy here in
node the Run evaluation so let's copy
this
paste it here and we will have two run
evaluations one will be with
knnn
and the other one will be with
MLP like so
so let's modify this run evaluation MLP
and the first thing we do here at the
top is rename our classifier to MLP like
that
and then reading it here from MLP JS and
here where we initialize our model
we don't have K and N instead we have
MLP and this MLP is going to take
the two parameters first the neuron
counts and we have five features at the
moment so the first neuron count is
going to be five
and the second one is going to be let's
just say directly the outputs and we
have eight different outputs
Car Fish House tree bicycle guitar
pencil clock and the second parameter we
pass are the classes which are
here and these hard-coded values we
don't have to keep them hard coded we
can just replace here five with
taking the training samples first item
there the point and the length of that
point and here is just the length of
these classes so now we don't have to
change these anymore they will work as
expected so this is a neural network
without a hidden layer it just connects
the inputs to the outputs directly and
we will experiment with hidden layers
later here you could pass a hidden layer
with maybe
10 neurons and another one with 10
neurons and one with five and so on but
at the moment we don't we just have this
simple connection
now let's copy this and replace every
time we want to do a prediction
n with MLP
and here also
that's it now let's run this new
evaluation I'm going to start the
terminal
make sure we're in the node directory
and node run evaluation
MLP this time
and it's really fast I didn't speed up
the video this time
it's also not very good this accuracy
here
is random chance if you've done homework
7 then you know this is random chance
and Leo Caesar 3D mentioned this in a
comment
now because this is based on Randomness
when we add the weights and biases every
time we run this evaluation we will get
a different value here
sometimes we're more lucky than others
because the networks that we are getting
just happen by chance to be a good or a
bad configuration
in the self-driving car course we
experimented with many different
networks and choosing the best so let's
try to do that here as well we will try
to fit the network to the training data
so let's open our MLP file here and
Implement a new method here called fit
the samples now we pass the samples to
this because it's going to need them but
it's not going to store them it's just
going to update the weights and biases
according to these samples somehow
you'll see and we'll use the same
strategy of Randomness and trial and
error we will try for example
one thousand times and keep the best
network that came
so
let's consider the best network being
the one in the class attributes and the
best accuracy
let's evaluate
that Network on the samples now we are
evaluating on the training data we are
not yet seeing testing data but we are
trying to improve the model this is okay
I'm going to now Loop
through this number of tries
and
let's try
to generate a new network
after we do that we evaluate its
accuracy
on the training samples
and if it's better than the best
accuracy
we keep it
and we also keep
the network
like so now here at the end we just set
this network to the best one that we
found
and we still need to implement this
evaluate method here
it's not complicated all we have to do
is
implement the method like that and count
how many of them are correctly predicted
when we Loop through all of the samples
take out the label and remember here to
destructure because that's what
MLP
predict will return
on the sample point
now the true value for this is what is
stored in the sample label we know the
true labels for our samples but if this
predicted label here matches the truth
then we increase the correct count so
correct count
increases if truth is equal to label one
otherwise it doesn't increase
and here we just calculate the accuracy
by dividing
correct count
by samples length and let's return this
accuracy let's save this file and in run
the evaluation MLP
after we initialize the MLP classifier
here we fit it to the training date
so MLP set training samples and let's
try this again I'm going to open now the
terminal and rerun the evaluation MLP
now we get 26.8
which is much better than the random
chance things we were getting previously
so it is working we are searching
through 1000 networks and if we're going
to increase here maybe by
I don't know 5000 then this accuracy
should be even better because now it's
trying even harder it's going through
even more
it's an expectation but of course you
can be really unlucky with those 5000
randomly generated networks and then
it's not gonna look sick
and it doesn't really make sense once we
have found the good one like this to go
back down to a crappier one so what we
could do is save this model every time
we find it and then load it when we do
this optimization so we can continue a
previously made optimization with the
saved Network as a basis let's save this
model so I'm going to type here
write file sync and
we will need the constant for where the
model should go
and then I'm just going to stringify the
whole MLP object
and that's it
now I want this model to be accessed
also by the web page so that we can try
the neural network there as well and I'm
going to use the same structure here
putting model
and JS also as a constant and here
initializing a variable called model
and then putting this stringified Json
inside of it and now let's close this
template literal like so now these
constants need to be added I'm going to
go here in constants.js
and let's copy this one for the decision
boundary this is going to be model now
and it's going to be in this models
directory let's call it model dot Json
and the JS object let's just copy this
min max here and this is going to be
model Js
and
now when we are going to run this
evaluation
this model with
31.96 percent accuracy is going to be
saved
in data models model here next to the
decision boundary
and if I'm gonna format it
you will see it has the neuron counts
information the classes information and
the network with all the levels
which is just one level for this one and
we have the inputs the five different
features the outputs the result of the
feed forward algorithm and here the
biases and the weights
through from all the inputs to all the
outputs now the inputs here and the
outputs here are just the last values
that have been used in the training
process they are meaningless every time
you do a classification these will
become overwritten with whatever the
features are and these here are going to
become generated from the feedforward
algorithm they're now just placeholders
here and that's okay
now if we want not to lose this model
and get at least
31.96 accuracy in the next model we have
to load this one
so in run evaluation MLP after we do
this initialization
let's load it from that file before we
do the fitting
so let's say here
if that file exists the one that
contains the model
I'm going to
mlp.load and parse it
after we read it
like so
now this load is a really simple method
that we still need to implement
here inside of mlpjs
I'm going to do it
just below the Constructor here
and load
given an MLP model I'm just going to
update this model's neuron count to that
ones
and the same thing for the classes
and the same thing for this network
it's basically a copy Constructor
now let's save this and rerun the
evaluation
and the same accuracy as before
we didn't get lucky with the 5000 tries
here but if we try again
still no luck if we try again
still nothing
but now it worked
so we could optimize like this
would take quite a long time to reach
the same level accuracies that we are
getting with our knnn
there are better optimizers than this
trial and error out there and we'll try
those later but now let's get this to
work on the web page as well
let me close some of these things
and here in viewer HTML
we are gonna have to import many
JavaScript files
so here we need the new MLP classifier
similar to the kmn classifier
then we also need that model the one
that we calculated on the back end
so this is here in JS objects the
JavaScript variant then we need the
neural network code and the visualizer
let me add this network JS here
underneath utils and the visualizer
here
from this JS folder
now we'll visualize this on another
canvas and I'm going to Define it here
inside of the chart container underneath
the confusion container so this is going
to be Network canvas
and it's going to be what we draw the
canvas on
let's give this a style similar to the
confusion container inside of styles CSS
the confusion container is here I'm just
going to copy it
below rename this to network canvas
and give it a black background
let's save this and close this file and
let's begin to work with the MLP
classifier
we won't use KNM anymore in this course
I'm going to keep it here for reference
but I'm going to start using the MLP
classifier
so MLP and I will initialize it with uh
empty and empty ear for the neuron
counts and for the classes because they
will be loaded from the model that we
have calculated with the scripts now
every time we see KNN here I'm going to
comment out the line
and
write MLP variant below so this happens
here when we are calculating the
accuracy of the testing samples but also
below for the real time processing here
so let's copy this
comment it out and replace KNN with MLP
so it's the same thing but now with the
different classifier
this should work already but we are not
visualizing it yet
so let me go here at the top and also
do the visualization I'm going to
set the width of the network canvas
500 and same for the height
and let's get a reference to the network
context from this network canvas
like so
now we also need the output labels to
look nice and we can get those
here after the graphics generate images
but let me just put this
maybe here above the sketch pad
and below the confusion because now we
have these related somehow so we
generate these output labels from the
styles by looking at the values
of the Styles and then remapping them so
we only take out the image of that style
we don't care about the color or the
text just the image component and then
we use our visualizer
to draw the network
on this network canvas
the network stored in our MLP classifier
and using these output labels that we
just defined
we also want to update the visualization
here after we do a real-time prediction
like so
and now let's save the file and we
should be able to test
the refresh the page
and something looks horribly wrong
I noticed that this width and height
features that we calculate for this
empty canvas are minus infinity and
minus infinity and this is causing some
problems now for this neural network it
was working okay for the KNN because it
was just some coordinate but now it's
sent to some calculations there and it's
causing some not a number to happen and
problems
so let's fix those functions real quick
I knew they will become an issue at some
point so inside of this feature
functions
at the top
our width here if the points are empty
if there is nothing there
I'm just going to return
0 for the width and same thing will
happen for the height as well
now let's refresh this page
and close this console
toggle the input
and now
the network does something here
it's saying that this is a car because
this car note here output value is the
highest and you can see that there's a
yellow color coding here blue means
negative values and the least visible
they are closer towards zero so this is
very visible bright yellow here it means
it's a high value
and um it's not fantastic
33.28 we had much better results but
that is what we can do now with this
random optimization strategy
and this here at the bottom are the
features so when we look at this we can
see a relatively high value for the
width because it's a wide image and this
is the height here which is smaller
then this is going to be the elongation
apparently quite the small value but if
we draw something like
this really elongated shape it's going
to be bright and then these final ones
are the round Miss value and this is not
round at all but if we do make it round
it's going to be bright and the last one
is the number of pixels basically
so if we would fill this space with a
lot of pixels then that one starts to
light up as well
and apparently it is able to pick up
that this is a clock one thing that I
still want to do is
toggle the output and this doesn't work
anymore
we need to rewrite it so that we
consider this one as well not just the
confusion Matrix and the chart so let me
go to
display JS and quickly rewrite this
from scratch
and I will just say that if the network
canvas
is visible then let's make this one
invisible and let's make the confusion
container
visible otherwise
if the confusion container
is visible
we will make it invisible
otherwise
we will make
both of them visible again
so now we are going to toggle between
the three items there
let's save this
refresh
and this seems to work
interestingly we get a lot of zeros here
so it looks like the network that we
have is really good at recognizing cars
and pencils and clocks
but nothing else so now we can see that
this accuracy really doesn't tell
a good story but this confusion Matrix
really tells us what is really going on
the model forgot about these other
things pretty much and let's see now in
this decision boundary plot we can't
really see much because it's still this
High dimensional Cube
but we could revert to the simple
features I like doing that let's go back
to width and height two features and see
how this decision boundary plot looks
like now when using a neural network
so
in feature functions I'm just going to
comment out here everything except for
these width and height
and let's open the terminal and let's
rerun the feature extraction
so node feature extractor.js
and now it's fast because it's not doing
the pixels thing
and now we have to optimize again our
neural network model but the model that
we created previously here inside of the
data models is pretty good and it's
using the five different features so
it's incompatible with the two feature
models that we try to create now and
we'll need to delete this for the code
to work
so right click delete the model
and now
run evaluation MLP
should work
we got a new model with 26.38 accuracy
now if I run this again it's going to
try 5000 more times and maybe get the
better version
or not let's try one more time see if
we're lucky
and we are we got 29 accuracy with this
one
and you'll notice that this decision
boundary plot is generated really
quickly now because
doing the feed forward algorithm is much
faster than doing the nearest neighbor
search
so we could go
in node here in the Run evaluation MLP
and set a higher value for this image
size to get a better quality image there
maybe 1000 is enough
now let's rerun this
took a bit longer but it's done and
accuracy didn't change so let's try to
refresh
and we see now this network with just
two nodes here the width and the height
just two features and the input layer
and the output it looks different but it
seems again the same kind of scenario
with just three things considered the
car the tree and the bike
now let's toggle again and this is now
the Precision boundary plot and it looks
interesting it has here at the top the
tree section and then the bicycle
section and then the car section this is
confusing me with the pencils so let's
go back to viewer HTML
and
put all the testing samples now I'm
going to comment out this filtering from
here
a refresh
and now we can see this decision
boundary plot and
every one of these trees here in the
green region is classified correctly
every one of these bikes here is
classified correctly and every one of
these cars here is classified correctly
but a lot of misclassifications happen
there is a pencil region here and
this car is in the pencil region so why
didn't it show up in our confusion
Matrix
oh it did it has a one here I didn't
notice it and the tree should be there
as well apparently
and there it is
hermino's house is also there classified
as a car nice now let's try one more
thing and see if we can add the hidden
layer here and if we get any difference
in our run evaluation MLP
at the top
let's say we are going to add
10 nodes on a hidden layer and see what
happens because we redo this evaluation
and the network that we have at the
moment doesn't have those I'm gonna have
to delete again this model here
and rerun the evaluation
a bit worse accuracy let's try to
improve it give it five thousand more
tries
doesn't seem to work one more try maybe
we're lucky
and we are not let's just keep it like
this and see what we have on the page
so this is how the neural neural
networks looks like and if we toggle the
inputs and we draw something really wide
you can see now this lighting up let's
make it also tall so this will light up
and a lot of things are lighting up here
in the middle in interesting ways when
these properties change so it's a more
complex model but not a very good one
it also seems to now prioritize two
things here let's see the decision
boundary plot
let's close this input
and I don't really see it so well
let's keep just the decision boundary
plot now here
and I'm going to add again this filter
because
it keeps that plot in a kind of squarish
aspect ratio because that's where the
pencils are there's no arminius house to
stretch things
so
let's hide the samples
and refresh
toggle the output
that's how it looks like
let's re-add all the features one last
time now with this hidden layer there
so in feature functions
I will remove this comment from here
and here
we go down and
feature extractor
it's done and now let's run evaluation
MLP
oh I forgot to remove that model that we
had last time
delete
and now run evaluation MLP
refresh and now the input layer is more
complex again
still this kind of bad looking confusion
Matrix
and this one is unreliable now because
we just showed the first two Dimensions
there
now optimizing this with the current
strategy is not going to work well you
could wait for it to randomly try a
bunch of different values and you could
leave it overnight or something you will
get better values
but next time I'm going to teach you how
to use Python to get the values with
more complex optimization algorithms
the neural network is now there but it
needs to be optimized better and the
typical way of doing this is with the
back propagation algorithm I don't have
a good way to teach it and the best
video I know on the topic is from three
blue one brown so go watch it what we'll
do is use back propagation in Python
there are some JavaScript
implementations as well but I wanted to
see that you can combine programming
languages like that and use their
strengths when needed python has many
machine learning libraries we'll
continue to use scikit-learn because we
use it in phase one but others are more
popular nowadays I think
it doesn't really matter all we need is
something that gives us good weights and
biases and paste them into our model
now get ready to blur the lines between
programming languages
make sure you have python installed for
this next part
last time we used python we were in this
python folder and we had this KNM py and
some functions for reading the CSV
features we're going to make a new file
similar to this KNN but we'll call it
MLP so copy
and paste it here
rename
MLP
and it's the same thing as k n for now
but we will include from this
scikit-learn Library not from Neighbors
this time but from neural network and we
import the MLP
classifier it has an implementation of
it already then here we write
MLP
MLP everything looks the same
but here we are going to have this MLP
classifier and these parameters don't
fit anymore instead we should pass the
number of hidden layers and actually how
many neurons should be on each hidden
layer
so we have to use a tuple for that and
at the moment I just have here 10
because I want it to be the same kind of
structure as we used last time in
JavaScript
so let's pass here this hidden
and now we can test
so let's open the terminal
we normally worked inside of this node
directory so if you're still there make
sure that you're gonna run this python
code by first going outside so
bison to running command and then
going outside of the node folder and
then python
mlp.py this is what we'll run this code
and looks like we're getting something
really good 61 percent and an error here
saying something about the optimization
not being finished yet and that's
because there is a parameter that we can
set to this classifier that it can
iterate longer so I'm going to pass this
set here Max either
to ten thousand and let's save this and
run this again
now we get
66 percent almost 67 percent which is
really good
now if you're gonna run this code again
it's possible that you're gonna get
another accuracy here
like now it changed slightly and that's
because it also uses randomness of some
kind
but if you want to have predictable
results here you can pass another
parameter and fix the random State it's
still going to use Randomness but now
the randomness is predetermined if that
makes sense so saving this and running
this
gives us some value now maybe 61 percent
I guess we weren't as lucky as we were
before
but it's consistent and if you change
this value to something else you will
get some other accuracies there some of
them will be more lucky some of them not
depending on your
luck I guess but I'm just gonna fix one
here I don't really care about the
accuracy that much
sixty percent is definitely very good
compared to what we were getting with
random chance but okay this is just one
of these printing in the console things
it's not so great how to get it to work
inside of our web application and see it
in practice
well we have to first debug what this
MLP object contains and I'm going to
start to print some of its properties
like the intercepts
so let's run this again
and you can see here two values pretty
much the first value here are 10 numbers
and these are the biases for the neurons
on the hidden layer the 10 neurons on
the hidden layer and these ones here are
the eight biases for the output neurons
the eight different classes we can also
print here the so-called coefficients
run this again
and now we're getting something much
bigger here
these are the weights
so
the weights are much longer than the
biases
so these intercepts and coefficients
need to go
over our model here if I'm going to
format this
we also have to specify in your own
counts and the classes here and then the
network
we have the different levels for each of
them we have inputs outputs and then the
biases and the weights
so the intercepts and the coefficients
are going to be the biases and the
weights we need to fill those in here
for all of the levels
but the inputs and outputs we don't need
to worry about that because these are
going to come in as a given the inputs
and the outputs are going to be
calculated by the network so really we
only need to pass here the weights and
the biases and also these things that
the model requires
so let me show you how to do that let's
remove here this and I'm going to need
to know what these classes are let's
define them in a list
Car Fish House tree
bicycle guitar pencil
clock
and now let's start forming our object
it's going to be this adjacent object
and the neuron counts now the values
from this are going to be the length of
X of 0 where we have the number of
features basically for the input layer
and then the hidden which is defined up
here
followed by
the length of the classes which we just
defined here
then
the classes I'm just going to pass this
object directly and then the network
this is going to be a dictionary here
with levels which is going to be an
empty list and now these Network levels
is what we have to fill in from the
intercepts and the coefficients
so I'm going to Loop
through all of the coefficients like
this
and let's define the level
with the weights and I'm going to
convert these coefficients
into a list and I'm going to do the same
thing with the intercepts
like so
and inputs is going to be just zeros I'm
just going to multiply them by how many
coefficients there are and outputs I'm
going to multiply them by how many
intercepts there
so these are just zeros and then we need
to append this level
to our Json object Network levels
so
this is a dictionary so we refer to the
Keys like that
and append
the level
now python does have a Json module and
we can import it here and use it to
define a Json objects
with an indent so we can read it more
nicely and now what we have to do is
write this Json object into our file
here that we will use in our viewer both
the one year and the models and the one
in JS objects here I will modify both of
them in Python so we don't have to worry
about it
let's open
the one in data models
model.json for writing
and
right
the Json object now I'm going to copy
this also for the JS object the
JavaScript object and this is going to
be in
common JS objects and model JS like that
and when we write it here we also need
to concatenate that string to assign it
to an object
so const model is equal to endless
concatenate with this and then here at
the end concatenate to it a semicolon
and now when we run this python code
again here in the terminal let me first
clear it up a bit
so if I'm going to run it again
it lists here the accuracy but our
models the model JS file here and also
the model Json file here should have
updated
with the new values so now the weights
are going to be
calculated from Python and the biases
come from Python and the inputs outputs
are turned into zeros
if we did everything correctly then now
we can run this
run evaluation MLP
and it's actually now trying to improve
that model if it can but most likely it
cannot and it's done
let's see it now in practice I'm gonna
refresh the page
and there you have it a neural network
that now has
61.79 accuracy
and if we toggle this we can see this
confusion Matrix looks much nicer
quite similar what we got with the k n
actually
and the decision boundary
not going to help us much in these high
dimensional spaces but we now have a
neural network here that actually is
able to recognize things quite nicely
quite well with
61.79 accuracy
nice
okay it's quite good actually now I
didn't plan to teach too many things
about neural networks here I plan to do
that in phase three of my self-driving
car course
after Phase 2 is done
but let's try to investigate a bit using
just two features again so we can see
also this decision boundary plot
coming from a good neural network
I'm going to go
here inside of common feature functions
and let's
keep just the width and the height again
and now let's do
feature extraction
with these two features only
and now let's do the training
with python
so we got a
42.3 percent accuracy with just two
features
which is comparable to the k n we got
previously with just two features now
let's run the evaluation so it generates
also the
decision boundary plot
and something looks off this 31.7
percent accuracy what
what happened
it was supposed to be 42 percent why did
it drop so much
Well turns out the reason is
the activation function that this MLP
classifier uses by default is the
rectified linear unit
and we will need to implement this
rectified linear unit into our
JavaScript code for it to be fully
compatible
let's do this
I'm gonna open here the network Js
and here where we're Computing the
outputs we need to apply this value
activation function here goes
done
it's just a maximum between zero and
that other value it doesn't like to have
negative values here
so let's save this
and now run this evaluation again
I should really turn off this trying to
optimize here let me go to run
evaluation MLP and here where we're
doing the fitting I'm just going to
decrease this value by a lot let's say
I will remove it so it defaults back to
1000. it's gonna be almost instantaneous
okay and now you actually see here the
accuracy being 42
.4 percent so the same as we got in
Python
and now let's test on the web page
there's the network and if we toggle the
output
it looks okay for just two features the
width and the height
and the decision boundary plot
looks like this it's much more
simple than the complex one we got
previously from KNN
but otherwise it's comparable in many
ways like a section here for the pencils
and one for the fish and this one for
the clocks I can obviously tell that
they are there now these activation
functions they are several of them and
you can check the documentation and the
scikit-learn library web page for
example if we go back in Python we can
actually pass them here
we could say activation set to
hyperbolic tangent for example
and this is going to be again one of
those really difficult ones to implement
but let's see first if it works so let's
try the hyperbolic tangent now
in Python here
it's not a big difference but I want to
show you just how the decision boundary
looks different
now let's implement this hyperbolic
tangent in JavaScript
and the good news is it's already there
the math library has an implementation
of it so we can just call it directly
here and remove that zero that we used
for the max previously
now let's run also the evaluation here
so that we get a new decision boundary
plot
and if we refresh
toggle the output
and again
you'll see that it looks more curved
because of what we just did
I think this way of learning is really
nice and if you're gonna go deeper and
study the mathematics behind the things
you're going to have an intuition of
what to expect
but yeah let's add all the features
again
and see what effect this hyperbolic
tangent has
on all of them
wow we got the 68 percent now
to see this on the web page we don't
really have to run the evaluation
anymore because the model is already
there and with so many features the
decision boundary plots are useless
pretty much so when we want to optimize
we can just run this python code and
open the viewer unless we change the
features as well then we have to do the
feature extraction again if we refresh
the viewer
this is what we get we have now this
neural network here and it starts to
have kind of a
structure it's not anymore completely
random if you look at the links
The Matrix here looks better and better
all the time almost 70 percent accuracy
so that's quite good
and this I won't bother with it anymore
we can check also down here in the
testing section
to see that a lot of blue started
appearing recently
and in many situations all the drawings
from one person are recognized
starts to feel like this is actually
doing something good
I decided to include this section on
deep neural networks so you don't ask
something like when are you going to
teach us something cool like deep neural
networks
well you already know how to use them
it's just a neural network that has many
connections many hidden layers and so on
I'm also going to teach you a way to go
from the five features we've been using
to 400 features but as you can see from
how long this video is it won't be
rocket science we'll just use the pixels
themselves as features so it won't
really be a deep dive this time we'll
only go Skin Deep
inside of feature functions
I'm going to comment out everything here
really
and we will implement
a different kind of code structure here
it will break what we have previously so
keep a backup of that if you want to
compare but we won't do many changes
today so you can also revert if you pay
attention
now what we do here is we open up an
object with the name pixel array so this
will have all the features coming from
one function call and the function is
going to be called on paths but then
it's going to return
all the pixels
from our get pixels function which we
call on the paths but I'm also going to
specify a size because I don't want to
have 400 times 400 pixels
that's going to be a lot of pixels and
they are not necessary we can figure out
what the drawing is even from a small
drawing and it's going to be more
efficient
so in my case here I'm going to use a
small 20 by 20 canvas now let's close
these and this is going to be a feature
Vector with 400 dimensions
now we need to change some things in the
code to work with this new structure and
we're going to go to node feature
extractor.js
and comment out this line here
and instead write this new one
that only takes out the values
of calling the first and only function
that we get from the feature functions
in use so we call this one here directly
on the paths and get the values assigned
them to the point now this feature names
at the moment would just say
pixel array here and that's not good
they need to be many of them 400 of them
so what we do here is comment out this
line and I'm gonna write this new one
where we create an array
the same size as the first samples Point
length
and we fill it with zeros or anything
you want really we can fill it with
an empty string like this
it just needs to have 400 items for the
code to work now for the web to work we
also have to do this for the real time
calculation of the features there
instead of this mapping here
and here we can just
take the first function
and call it underpaths like so now this
should work if we open now
the terminal we can extract these new
features let's go to the node
folder and then
extract these new features
and let's have a quick look
what they are
inside data
data set
and now let's for example open these
csvs they are easier to read
you can see at the top the feature names
they are those empty strings separated
by commas
and there are many of them 400 of them
and last thing is still the label
and then
here there are pixel values visible
pixels here and some pixels may not be
fully visible because of this
anti-aliasing
but some pixels are completely invisible
and
this is the
whole very long feature Vector for each
individual sample
so can this work
well if I'm going to optimize now with
python
it seems it does and we're now at 70
almost 75 percent
wow let's take a look in the web page
and we now have this Beast here
with all these connections here from
each individual pixel all 400 pixels of
the small 20 by 20 size image and this
is the new accuracy
this is the new Matrix here and it looks
really really good doesn't it
this we already said we don't look at
anymore with these high number of
Dimensions there
and if we try to make a new input here
it seems to work and I made these nodes
here very very small in the visualizer
if they exceed a certain value
now if you want to get an even nicer
visualizer here that somehow modifies
also the weights based on the activation
of these bottom neurons here
then you could go in the visualizer
and go to draw level
and here we're drawing these weights
between the inputs and the outputs so
they are the lines and we set here the
value the rgba of the weight value but
we can multiply this by the
inputs of
I and this is going to make that
connection disappear if that pixel is
off or be there present if the pixel is
on because of that
anti-alias saying it could be also some
transparent value
so let's save this
refresh and now everything is off here
but if we start drawing something
we start to see there
those connections appearing and I think
it's interesting it makes this a much
more dynamic system
this is not a pencil oh come on
maybe if we give it some more detail
like
okay now it's a fish
great but um this is not yet a deep
neural network because it just has this
one hidden layer
let's go deeper
we're going to go to our python script
let's put
100 nodes on this one hidden layer for
now and then we try more later
so let's optimize again
82 percent accuracy we broke another
barrier there at 80 percent
let's see how this one looks like
and this is it
wow look at that
now this system starts to become slow
because of this visualization here
but also because the model becomes more
complex and there are more calculations
I think we can try with two hidden
layers so that we do get some deep
Network
even though deep means a lot of them but
you get the idea
let's add 100 more
83 percent not a very very big
Improvement but it's still an
improvement
now let's see how it looks like
so now we have this
and if we draw something
a lot of crazy stuff happening there
and it is a house
it seems to be quite reliable like after
it's a house it's it's a house here
let's see our confusion Matrix one more
time
and yeah this looks really good
and let's have a look also at the
classifications
very few of them are not blue right now
now people have different views here
some like the small models with
relatively few features and consider big
models like what we just built as a
waste of resources but others think
they're worth it because you can teach
them pretty much anything without the
pain of tailoring features one by one
the problem is it's really hard to
explain why the system works a certain
way if the model is so big
hope you liked the course let me know if
you want to see more like I didn't teach
you anything about clustering yet and
it's an important part of machine
learning or we could try to identify the
person who is doing the drawing instead
of what is being drawn maybe we can make
a really sophisticated authentication
system like that
what do you think go in the poll in the
description and vote your favorite
see you guys